Куди не кинь поглядом – скрізь колючий дріт.
Селище Кюбекгаза на угорсько-сербському кордоні.
Мер Роберт Молнар хоче показати нам,
як загорожа від мігрантів уплинула на життя в його громаді.
Однак прикордонники перешкоджають нам.
- У вас є дозвіл на зйомку?
- Ні, але в Угорщині ж свобода преси, чи не так?
Але прикордоннику немає справи до свободи преси:
або дозвіл, або забирайтеся.
- Ближче не підходьте, інакше отримаєте удар струмом.
Врешті-решт нам дозволяють зйомку.
Я не хочу жити в країні, де панує атмосфера,
як тут на кордоні. І дітям своїм такого не побажаю.
Боюся, що одного разу ми самі станемо біженцями.
Свободу преси в Угорщині згорнули.
В країні сформована система корупції.
І це, за словами Молнара, вже повністю
відчувають на собі  мешканці Кюбекгази.
Тут проживають півтори тисячі людей.
Вони переважно зайняті у сільському господарстві
та дрібному виробництві.
За урядування Орбана їхній небагатій громаді
припинила надходити державна підтримка.
Торік, за словами мера,
Будапешт перерахував їм цілих 4 євро.
Однак Роберта Молнара це не лякає.
Він, як і раніше, критикує правопопулістський уряд.
У селищі скрізь майоріють прапори Євросоюзу,
це теж - форма протесту.
Я вважаю, що приналежність до Європи – це фундаментальна річ для нас, угорців.
Не можна нацьковувати людей один на одного.
Це підло – заробляти політичний капітал, створюючи образ ворога.
Мер, схоже, має на увазі, в тому числі,
керівника сусіднього містечка.
Морагалом розташований за 30 кілометрів звідси,
біля тієї ж загорожі.
Тут повсюди відреставровані пам‘ятники й новобудови.
А у центрі - величезна ратуша.
Ось тільки європейських прапорів ніде не видно.
Усередині засідає мер Золтан Нограді.
Він є членом правоконсервативної правлячої партії.
І не вважає за сором зізнатися,
що політика уряду йде на користь йому та "його" місту.
Мені видається, що громади, які не отримують держпідтримки,
овинні критично поглянути на себе.
Адже тут існує принцип взаємності:
якщо мер провокує центральну владу,
він має бути готовим до провокацій у відповідь.
У Морагаломі є дещо, що явно сподобається
націоналістам з Будапешта.
Співробітниця мерії показує нам парк "Міні-Угорщина".
Колишня мрія про велику імперію, в малому форматі.
Тут відтворено Велику Угорщину.
Ви бачите лише ті будівлі,
кі перебували на історичній території країни.
Вочевидь, завдяки такому прославленню минулого
на місто щедро ллються державні дотації у сьогоденні.
Великі кошти виділено, зокрема, на оновлення міського освітлення.
Це велике замовлення здобула фірма "Еліос".
На думку Європейського бюро у боротьбі з шахрайством,
це був нечесний тендер.
Фірма належить зятю угорського прем‘єра Орбана.
Все відбувалося відповідно до правил.
У підсумку замовлення отримала фірма "Еліос".
Я докладно не перевіряв, яким чином її відбирали.
Опозиційно налаштований мер Роберт Молнар
називає це типовою практикою уряду Орбана.
В угорського уряду є три підходи до власних громадян.
Їх або купують, або представляють як сумнівних осіб,
або просто затуляють їм рота.
Надвечір Роберт Молнар знову біля кордону
І меру видається, що цей кордон
проходить уже не лише між двома державами,
але й посеред угорського суспільства.